nice ville martyre c'est le titre à la
une ce vendredi de nice matin le
quotidien local martyr parce que c'est
la troisième fois depuis 2015 que nice
est victime du terrorisme
c'est donc tout un peuple qui est en
deuil ce vendredi au lendemain de
l'attaqué perpétrée dans la basilique
notre dame de l'assomption qui se trouve
juste derrière moi une attaque au
couteau qui a coûté la vie à trois
personnes et qui a été perpétré par un
tunisien de 21 ans qui est arrivé tout
récemment sur le seul français au début
du mois d'octobre
face au terrorisme eric ciotti député
les républicains des alpes-maritimes
appel à une législation d'exception une
grande colère face à l'impuissance
aujourd'hui que nous avons à mieux
protéger les français
j'appelle depuis des années à ce qu'on
réagisse qu'on se lève con ce qu'on
change de cadre pour lutter contre
contre l'islamisme contre le terroriste
le terrorisme islamiste
ça n'a pas toujours été suivies d'effet
et il faut le faire avec beaucoup plus
de force et je pense aujourd'hui qu'il
faut changer de cadre et qu'il faut
changer de méthode savoir ce qu'on veut
pour se protéger il ya des gens qui nous
menacent et soit on se laisse abattre
soit on mène le combat crois qu'il ya
pas le choix autrement on va aller vers
un cortège de drames de plus en plus
fort depuis hier de nombreux niçois
chrétien juif musulman ou encore raté se
sont déplacés pour rendre hommage aux
victimes pour soutenir la communauté
chrétienne victimes de cet attentat
beaucoup de monde encore aujourd'hui au
moment où je vous parle comme vous
pouvez le voir être derrière moi et des
personnes qui ont tenu et bien à venir
allumer une bougie à déposer des fleurs
des petits mots je vous propose
d'écouter ces quelques témoignages c'est
malheureux mais j'ai grandi ici et c'est
vraiment très désagréable en fait c'est
déjà ils n'ont pas de coeur en fait
j'étais venu pour mettre une bougie à
l'intérieur et puis comme c'est fermé
ben je reviendrai toute la france
devrait plat vous l'avez entendu je leur
ai donc au recueillement
un sentiment partagé par plusieurs
membres des différentes communautés
religieuses locales elles certains
d'entre eux sont d'ailleurs fait le
déplacement ce matin pour notamment
promouvoir le vivre ensemble et le
dialogue interreligieux
même en une émotion et partager avec
tous les français je dis bien tous les
français parce que c'est quelque chose
qui est arrivé dans une église où des
gens qui ont une foi une religion
viennent pour remercier dieu pour la vie
qu'ils ont
et que tout d'un coup il ya des gens
fanatiques qu'il entre dans cette église
que pour tuer et sa soi-disant au nom de
deux de dieu qui est un lieu qu'elle
dure voudrais que les gens les êtres
humains meurent personne un être humain
c'est quelqu'un qui est en relation
nous ne pouvons pas vivre les uns les
uns sans les autres alors soyons forts
prenons courage comme dit l'écriture
soyons forts prenant courage et allons
allons de l'avant sans pour autant
quitter le sentiment d'effroi de
tristesse et de recueillement inclinons
nous devant la mémoire de ceux qui sont
tombés et évitons toute récupération
politique politicienne toute
récupération qui serait indigne c'est
dans ce contexte que le conseil français
du culte musulman a appelé ce matin les
musulmans de france a annulé les
festivités du maoulid cette fête
musulmane qui commémore la naissance du
prophète célébrée depuis hier et qui se
poursuit aujourd'hui
le porte parole de la conférence des
évêques de france a lui aussi a réagi il
a dit je cite refusé de céder à la peur
que l'on veut nous imposer